ça m'a donné envie de chanter carnaval
le mardi gras carnaval des années c'est
la saison on voulait comme rio vous oui
j'avais envie de dire à québec c'est
tout un festival
là ça se passe à rio d'accord on vous en
montrer derrière des images c'est la
période effectivement des carnavaliers
aujourd'hui ma connerie c'est la
vendirent a bondi grâce effectivement
histoire de mardi gras qu'est ce qui
détermine le mardi gras mercredi 10 ans
karen tout ça et aussi par la lune
le cycle lunaire et d'ailleurs j'ai
sorti mes calendriers pour qu'on garde
ça ensemble
alors aujourd'hui effectivement c'est le
mardi gras mardi le 5 une période de
festivités avant le mercredi des cendres
qui va amener vous savez cette grande
période du carême qui était davantage
respectée avant et sachez que pâques
cette année c'est le 21 mai avant cette
période du carême les carnavals et
regardez d'ailleurs le mot qui vient
latin carbis lévaré raymond oui je fais
mon professeur aujourd'hui car nice les
marées hautes et la viande la chair
alors ça veut dire que c'est une période
de festivités et les carnavals y en a
partout dans le monde on le disait
carnaval de québec
ionis de venise mais regardez celui ci
la bolivie a vraiment des carnavals y en
a partout février également donc en mars
mais le carnaval le plus important de la
planète vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est le carnaval de rio
reygadas quel point ces spectaculaires
d'ailleurs on dit qu'il s'agit du plus
grand spectacle du monde
ça se passe vous savez notamment macadré
parce que vous êtes à lario au
sambodrome ont alors une espèce de rue
avec des grandes estrades et ce sont des
écoles de samba qui s'affrontent et
regardez même il y avait jean paul
gaultier c'est le style jean paul
gaultier effectivement raison
semble-t-il également donc avec madonna
et saas continue jusqu'aux petites
heures du matin
soixante douze mille spectateurs
rapidement vous dire vous allez
connaître qui est elle est fière neymar
oui mais grand footballeur qui est
blessé qui joue pas pour lui ce sont
exactement ils vont retourner sables est
une au psg à paris
lors des récents paris l'a vu en photo
mais il y avait beaucoup de plaisir
parce qu'il est brésilien également donc
il a participé donc à cette festivité et
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui à omettre le
collier merci beaucoup monsieur ça se
passe vous savez la nouvelle orléans le
mardi gras dont il y aura plusieurs
défis environ soixante dix un peu
partout dans la ville
à suivre avec des images trop
spectaculaire